[Aplausos]
si un señor no se logra es porque de
verdad no se deseaba la pregunta es
ustedes ya llegaron a sus sueños ya
tienen sus metas completas sí ya está
todo perfecto
bueno pues mi vida cambió cuando tenía
17 años me embaracé tuve a mi preciosa
hija canal tele puse igual para
arruinarle la vida y que se burlen de
ella como sean por lo de mi claro
y cuando la tuve con 17 años que eran
nada de experiencia no tenía dinero no
tenía educación no tenía universidad ni
siquiera tenía preparatoria hay muchas
muchas mujeres que se atan que cuando ya
tienen un hijo tienen un problema les
pasa cualquier cosa dicen o ya está aquí
me quedo mi zona de confort ya no les
digo me paro pero para mí no para mí al
revés fue realmente una motivación fue
mesa con la furia ya saben él fue me
sacó entonces paso número uno primero
mantenernos entonces tuve que vender
ropa y bolsas para poder mantenerlos
paso número dos acabar la preparatoria y
paso número tres empezar con la
universidad ya cuando acabe mi carrera
profesional mi hija dijo que padre mi
mamá ya va a estar conmigo todas las
tardes ya no a tener clases en la tarde
porque a veces tiene clases en la tarde
pero no eso no iba a pasar porque cuando
entras a una empresa de alto prestigio
como bien saben ustedes tienes trabajo
de sol a sol entonces tienes trabajo
todo el tiempo
y yo sabía que en esa empresa que ya me
habían contratado no iba a poder estar
en las tardes entonces dije ya sé voy a
emprender si pongo una empresa ya voy a
poder estar con ella todas las tardes
ingenuamente porque ya pasaron ocho años
y sigo esperando que mis tardes sean
mías no ha pasado pero bueno la pregunta
era que voy a emprender
cuál era mi pasión en la vida a mí no me
gustaban las motocicletas ni las
bicicletas ni dibujar no soy buena para
eso no soy buena cantando entonces cuál
era mi idea a qué me iba a dedicar no
tenía esta pasión y decidí hacer una
matriz que es muy sencilla pero muy
reveladora la cual se llama foda no sé
si lo ubiquen en la escuela y se le
enseñaron a lo mejor las fuerzas y las
debilidades son internas las amenazas y
las oportunidades son externas yo con
esto descubrió que tenía una fortaleza
muy grande que era vender me gusta
vender de verdad me apasiona vender soy
buena para hablar en público creo que no
me da tanta pena eso creo encontré una
oportunidad muy grande que era la
cultura mexicana está muy bien
posicionada en el extranjero y tenemos
productos fabulosos en ser una
oportunidad una debilidad lo acepto
me choca me molesta que crean muchas
veces que nosotros vivimos abajo de un
opal que no estamos súper desarrollados
que somos de lo peor y eso me molesta
que aquí solo
incoherencia y solo hay robos eso no es
verdad me molesta que crean que las
artesanías no sirven para poder exportar
que no son dignas de todo el mundo
porque no tienen la suficiente calidad
eso realmente me duele y una amenaza muy
grande es que actualmente se están
perdiendo cada vez más las tradiciones
las nuevas generaciones ya no ubican
bien que era lo que hacía la abuelita
por ejemplo día de muertos para nosotros
ahora ya está súper reemplazado por
halloween y así podemos pasar por
cualquier parte del mundo las
tradiciones están perdiendo entonces
llegué a la conclusión de que mejor
ponía una exportadora de arte mexicano
la pregunta era ahora y qué voy a
exportar porque investigue y vi que el
número uno a nivel mundial que ubicaba a
la gente muy bien culturalmente era el
mariachi pero no iba exportar gente eso
no está cool eso es cómo trata de
blancas no está padre entonces exportar
gente lo descartamos luego sería el
tequila pero el tequila yo sólo tenía 30
mil pesos
pequeño problema treinta mil pesos son
como mil 700 dólares más o menos no me
alcanzaba ni para una parcelita no ni
para y ahí lo aparte seis años para que
salga el maguey y el tequila no eso está
muy complicado no hice ya la piñata la
piñata era la siguiente la número tres
por cierto mi número favorito
entonces la piñata está perfecta porque
que tiene la piñata diversión risas
acerca la familia te acerca a los amigos
a casa y la furia la ira al pegarle está
padrísimo y aparte está en revistas está
en televisión en series incluso por si
no saben hay una una consola sacó un
juego de vídeo que también se llama
piñata está padrísimo eso está perfecto
pero una piñata normal pues hay muchas
piñatas normales y lo que yo quería que
era hacer pues de exportar a todas
partes del mundo entonces cómo iba a
exportar una piñata si se va a maltratar
se va a romper se va a dañar
entonces llegué al océano rojo el océano
rojo y el océano azul
les va a explicar más o menos qué es el
océano rojo es donde estamos ahorita a
todos es el mercado normal en donde la
única diferencia que existe entre un
producto y otro es el precio o sea que
aquí yo te doy el 25 por ciento de
descuento y yo aquí te doy carta de
tarjeta de cliente frecuente y aquí te
doy un producto más y te regalo unas
galletas en compra de una mayonesa pero
eso no es innovación eso solo es la
diferencia que hace entre un producto de
otro en el océano rojo el océano azul es
hacer algo totalmente diferente algo
innovador salir de la zona de confort
para darles un ejemplo están los circos
normales los circos normales están en el
océano rojo porque porque ellos tienen
varias pistas varios shows tienen
animales siempre te estás riendo en un
circo normal hay comida en los
intermedios y qué pasa en circo du
soleil todo lo contrario
anti do pues la calidad de la comida y
las bebidas super diferentes no comida
en los pasillos el precio es muy
diferente no todo el tiempo te estás
riendo y te estás muriendo de la
preocupación por el peligro de que si se
mata el pobre hombre
acá no acá a veces sufre este pones
triste te emocionas te ríes también no
no hay palabras tal cual la música es en
vivo todo es muy diferente
las dos están iguales son circos y están
en entretenimiento sin embargo es todo
lo contrario otro ejemplo muy claro y
muy rápido son las consolas de
videojuego ante las consolas siempre
estaba sentado era su president ario
porque el que estamos con el control y
jugabas y listo se acabó
una consola salió el océano azul de las
consolas y ahora puedes batear puedes
cocinar puedes correr pues la respuesta
hacer de todo pero el control es tu
cuerpo
eso está padrísimo porque le quitaron el
problema a los papás los papás estaban
hartos de que sus hijos estuvieran ahí
aplastado test sin hacer nada
y entonces así es como llegué a la
piñata porque lo que es muy importante
es no quitar lo que es básico de una
piñata entonces básico de una piñata que
es tiene que ser una piñata grande
colorida que le quepan dulces por
supuesto que se rompa eso es lo básico
porque necesitamos eso si no no es
piñata pero cuando han visto una piñata
que venga en una caja que tenga una
marca que tenga fotos en la caja que
tenga instrucciones eso no existe
entonces es el océano azul de la piñata
sin embargo cuando tú la ves
le caben aquí cuatro kilos de dulce
las sierras en unos segunditos y la
rompes como una piñata normal es una
piñata convencional grande estorbosa de
caben dulces pero
la puedes mandar a cualquier parte del
mundo y puedes decorar y desde corazón
entonces esa fue la diferencia entre el
océano azul y el océano rojo para que
les cuento todo esto no me importa que
sepan la historia de la piñata me
importa que ustedes llegan a las
conclusiones de que están haciendo en
sus empresas en sus personas con su
familia con su pareja en su trabajo no
importa que no sean emprendedores qué es
lo que están haciendo como lo están
haciendo a dónde están llegando
para mí mi motivación pues era mi hija
como les conté mi método el que yo usé
fue el foda y luego los enanos entre
evidentemente muchos otros pero fueron
los que basaron mi empresa y después
llega la materialización y ya con esto
pues hice la caja y de la piñata hice la
empresa y se todo
pero todo esto no importa si tú no estás
bien por dentro no importa cuántos
libros hayas leído o si tienes doctorado
o maestría no importa qué tan rico seas
no importa nada si tú no estás bien por
dentro
para mí es súper importante este círculo
es nosotros mismos como estamos
estructurados para mí es súper
importante el perdón y el gracias porque
gracias a estas dos palabras podemos
llegar a la felicidad
entonces la felicidad es la base de todo
esto
les voy a confesar algo que no me suele
gustar decir de hecho muy pocas personas
lo saben
pero hace cuatro años a mí me robaron
dos millones de pesos que eso es un mil
que no 115 mil dólares aproximadamente
pues si fue alguien súper de confianza
que yo creí confiar y me dijo sin nada
pero no importa que nada me haya dejado
sin dinero que me dejó en la ruina
yo tenía 64 colaboradores ya sea 22 mil
piñatas mensuales y todas estaban
vendidas y me dejó en la ruina me quedé
sin nada deja todo el dinero es lo de
menos como dicen pero porque ellos no lo
han perdido hello
pero me dejó sin alma me la robó de
verdad se los juro estaba súper
deprimida no creía en dios ya no quería
levantarme no quería comer no quería
saber nada de nadie me ven era horrible
de verdad me robó el alma y eso es lo
más difícil de recuperar
me costó muchos años hace un año me
llamaron de hair time méxico y estuve a
2 del pib y sólo por el miedo de pararme
en una cámara y decía a nivel nacional
soy una tonta porque me deje robar 2
millones de pesos gracias me daba tanta
pena tanta vergüenza a aceptar lo que
estuve a punto de decir que no pero
gracias tuve el valor y fui
y hoy por primera vez en mi vida porque
nunca lo he hecho
y lo voy a hacer para ustedes porque de
verdad me preparé porque quiero el día
de hoy superarlo y le digo señor x
gracias por haberme robado de verdad
gracias y te perdono te perdono porque a
mi me hiciste más fuerte solo me
enseñaste que soy una fregona y que me
puedo levantar y que tirán otra vez
porque me voy a levantar y más grande
voy a hacer del juro
muchas gracias de verdad por eso
gracias
yo sé que no es fácil perdonar de verdad
que los vean me robaron hace cuatro años
y es la primera vez que lo puedo decir
y como lo pueden denotar no es nada
fácil pero los invito a que ustedes
también lo hagan ustedes creen que
realmente las personas que los dañaron
las que los robaron los pitos sortearon
o les dijeron de cosas en serio ellos
están preocupados en sus casas diciendo
hay pobre juanita la daño horrible ahí
es que pobre maria tal vez éste todavía
no lo supera verdad o bien no les vale
ustedes son los que realmente están
sufriendo las consecuencias de estos
actos ustedes son los que traen la
mochila que atrás y son los que vienen
cargando son los que no pueden ser
plenos felices llenos
agradezcan la vida qué pasó eso porque
les enseñó algo bueno y perdonen los por
eso es que los invito a que hagamos un
ejercicio juntos esto no es cero ni
religioso ni nada simplemente es algo
que a mí me funciona y lo quiero
compartir por favor todos cierren los
ojos
y inhalen y piensen que les entra la luz
blanca pero muy luminosa que les llena
toda la cabeza y luego les llena el
pecho les recorre los brazos y las
piernas y ahora ex al en obscuridad
todos los bichos ponzoñosos piedras todo
lo feo todo lo malo que tienen ahí
adentro exhale loco
una vez más con los ojos cerrados
inhalen luz
ec salen todo el mal y por última vez
inhalen todo el amor todos los recuerdos
buenos todo lo bonito que han tenido en
la vida cuando nació su hijo cuando se
graduaron inhalen esa luz hermosa
y exhale en plenitud libertad siéntanse
libres
ahora les pido que abren los ojos y
recuerden si un sueño no se logra es
porque de verdad ustedes no lo deseaban
lo suficiente gracias
[Aplausos]